D for delivery and that delivery by
defra
priorities for defer I hope indicate how
we will work together in the years ahead
now conference we are meeting at a time
when we are all still feeling the
economic aftershocks of covid
with Global Supply chains still
recovering and exacerbated by The
Fallout from Russia's illegal invasion
of Ukraine one of the most important
agricultural countries in the world
having an impact on everything from the
cost of inputs to the price of food
impacts that are causing sleepless
nights for families across the country
for many of you and indeed right around
the world
now we can be proud of the way that we
are standing shoulder to shoulder with
Ukraine
through this terrible ordeal
including our support for the heroic
Farmers getting the Harvest in amid the
turmoil of war and sharing it with some
of the world's poorest and most
vulnerable people
and while we may have rejoiced at the
video of Ukraine tractors Towing away
Russian tanks we extended financial
support for the grain from Ukraine
program and critically with our
scientific expertise on grain
verification we are protecting their
grain from being stolen by the Russians
and frustrating the Russian efforts to
profit from theft
it's vitally important that we continue
to stand with our allies in defense of
the freedom democracy and common decency
that we treasure so deeply
back in the UK all this comes on top of
the impact of historic flooding and
drought in an ever-changing climate
as Mark Spencer set out yesterday we
understand the pressures you are under
we have sought to help even further with
the cash flow challenges you face
now we'd already put in place the
farming profit averaging tax relief
last year we also brought forward BPS
payments to be twice a year for the
first time ever in which we will
continue to do
and recognizing that particularly
villarent strain of Avian Influenza we
introduced urgent measures to protect
the sector we kept the free-range brand
going and we modified the compensation
scheme
we acted to help with Rising input costs
including action on fuel Duty energy
bills and business rates and it's why we
will strengthen our Focus nationally on
energy security as well as the supply
supplies of critical minerals and
fertilizer we need
and why we must continue to work
together to forge a more secure more
sustainable future for farming so we can
feed a changing world
conference
we are on a journey in agriculture
we finally left the European Union we
still have a strong trade agreement with
the EU and we are expanding our trade
agreements around the world
they are a two-way street and our new
dedicated agricultural attaches in key
markets are bolstering our efforts to
increase exports in addition to what our
Diplomatic Corps are already doing on
trade
now leaving the cap with its tick box
approach accompanied by the tape
measures the tucked up tones alongside
the threat of fines clawbacks infraction
measures
it's really given us the opportunity to
design a new way to support our farmers
and Achieve public goods for public
money
our shared Mission across Society is to
reach Net Zero and strengthen the
resilience of our environment so that in
turn we strengthen the resilience of our
businesses and our communities
and I find farmers are the first to
insist that these things can and must go
hand in hand if we are to improve the
prosperity in food security of every
generation to come as well but without
these we won't even have a future a
future Eve to even consider
now the combination of environment and
agriculture in one Department under one
secretary of state is
pretty rare if not unique around the
world
has allowed us to design policies and
funding schemes schemes that are not
combative but intended to be
complementary to make space for nature
and continue sustainable food production
they're not mutually exclusive
in fact I believe the two can and must
be symbiotic and practice a lot of this
is not new it's rediscovering to some
extent the agricultural techniques of
our parents and grandparents
marrying them with the latest scientific
innovation access to clean water
healthier and productive soil abundant
pollinators these are all absolutely
critical to producing good food and as
the nfu have regularly pointed out
tackling climate change is key for the
industry
that's why we've worked with you to
design develop and deploy new and much
improved programs It's Our intention to
make it straightforward for Farmers to
participate whether you're a tenant or
landowner an Upland farmer or commoner a
new entrant or a veteran
moving away from a system where over
half the subsidy went to just 10 percent
of the farmers with based on how much
land you had
towards choosing from our pick and mix
menu which is deliberately flexible so
you can choose what works best for your
farm as part of your plan to improve the
productivity profitability
sustainability and resilience of your
business for the future
and I recognize that you also need
access to labor steady energy and
fertilizer prices a good deal with
buyers and strong biosecure borders
I will continue to work on all of these
issues and more alongside mark
but we are on that Journey now from cap
to Elms it was my predecessor Michael go
who laid the foundations and mapped out
the journey with the health and Harmony
white paper back in 2018 which is
reinforced by our 2019 Manifesto George
Eustis piloted the agriculture act
through Parliament and set about
designing the smooth transition
and as we make these changes the total
level of funding to Farmers absolutely
remains unchanged that's 2.4 billion
pounds just as we committed in our
Manifesto and we also set in our out in
our national food strategy how we want
to help farmers and consumers we made a
commitment to Parliament on the state of
a report on the state of our nation's
food security at least once every three
years and currently we have
self-sufficiency just under about
two-thirds providing us with amazing
food from Farm to fork and we want to
maintain at least that if not consider
higher something we will be discussing
at the forthcoming food security Summit
later this year just as the Prime
Minister assured humanet but we know
that the security of your businesses is
not just about funding you can get from
the government far from it while A is
for agriculture B is for biosecurity
that's biosecurity at the borders of our
of the country and at the borders of
individual Farms
of course our borders can and Must Be an
Effective first line of defense in
securing a safe healthy environment and
safe healthy food helping us to tackle
problems before they can spread
in the market confidence in the
outstanding quality of the goods that we
produce country and trade with our
partners around the world that is a key
element of our new plant biosecurity
strategy our plan for the next five
years of action and we will be saying
even more soon about how we'll be
enhancing biosecurity controls at our
borders even further to make things more
straightforward and less burdensome
embracing Innovation and digitization
and targeting those frankly who let the
side down while trusting those who
consistently do the right thing
so we will incentivize compliance
support the flow trade and promote the
high standards that are synonymous with
the best of British around the world
but from the very dark days of foot and
mouth to the fight against African swine
fever to the ongoing fight against
salmonella and to eradicate bovine TB by
we know from experience
just what is at stake and that action on
farms is critical
now in some areas and some markets we're
only just recovering from events that we
endured decades ago
and frankly I have to say this keeps me
up at night as just as it does many of
you
so now I know that we all want to do
whatever we can to make sure that no
farmer no business no Community has to
go through anything similar ever again
and it's right that as well as investing
in our first phase 200 million pounds
into our site capability in the animal
health program at weybridge we're making
sure you have the support you need to
improve Animal Welfare as a vitally
important part of our plans through the
Animal Health and Welfare pathway so we
stop diseases from spreading like
wildfires we know they can but we also
need to grasp Innovation opportunities
Farmers have always been at the heart of
Animal Health and Welfare and we know
it's absolutely vital to strengthen the
biosecurity and preventing diseases
indeed data on this unprecedented
outbreak of Avian Influenza both in
scale and spread in wild birds and
poultry Farms underlines the need for us
to rise to the increased threats of
diseases
and for each infection in recent months
a weakness in on-farm biosecurity has
often been found as the most likely
source of infection so we need to
address that as a matter of urgency
in all cases we will continue to push to
make sure that we are tackling the
issues at source and throughout the
supply chain where that is if what is if
that is what is needed as well
and of course taking actions to secure
good animal uh health is at the heart of
our plan to make even greater progress
on reducing our Reliance on antibiotics
as well so we take on that threat of
antimicrobial resistance that is already
costing more than a million lives around
the world every single year
we know that it works and we've more
than halved our usage so we are working
with you to do even more
and where technology can help us harness
the awesome power of nature like the
plant science and precision breeding
improve
props we need to do even more to combine
the power of our world-leading
scientific expertise
with the energy of entrepreneurial
Enterprise
we need to get Cutting Edge
game-changing technology and Innovation
out of labs and into the fields
breakthroughs like the new strains of
wheat being developed at the John Innes
Center in Norwich that are more
resistant to climate change and more
resilient to pests they have a huge
potential to help us feed the world and
do it without the need for quite so many
pesticides particularly those harmful to
pollinators
but we need to scale up and it's
important that are so important our
prime minister has just created a brand
new Department to give it leadership and
focus so I expect our prominent research
institutes to start to take advantage of
the new freedoms that we are bringing to
life including through the Precision
breeding bill that the nfu of supported
in the get-go and it should receive
Royal assent very soon
I turned to see and I talked about
conservation I spent quite a lot of time
on nature but C can also be for the
countryside
I want us to respect and support our
cherish we're always alive
whether that's making sure people can
enjoy the beauty of our Landscapes and
coastlines
and do so responsibly
or making sure that a young person in
rural Cornwall El Cumbria feels that
they can have the opportunities they
need to flourish leveling up the things
that help people live long and
fulfilling lives wherever they live
that's exactly what we are doing set out
on our rural proofing report last year
we're making also making sure we secure
the future of Village Halls that are the
Hub of communities across the country to
investing in your connectivity tripling
the value of vouchers now available
under the gigabit Broadband voucher
scheme making sure people working the
most rural parts of the Lake District
can be as connected as people here in
the heart of Birmingham we continue to
have new trials that have been Broadband
in the hardest to reach rural areas
directly from satellites in space and
we'll keep we're funding The Institute
for agriculture and Horticulture to help
create the conditions we need to retain
generations of experience develop
promising talent and attract new
recruits into the sector
and we want to support the productivity
of our rural businesses and my
department will ensure that rural is a
common core component of the
government's leveling up mission
now rarely need there be a conflict
between conservation and the countryside
but I saw firsthand in Suffolk very
early as an MP in fact as a candidate
that when there was a proposal to
reintroduce the sea eagle
farmers were really worried about what
this would do to their livestock
particularly given the extent of
free-range farming in that part of the
country
now while we've had some successful
translocations and reintroductions to
species
I don't want Farmers to constantly have
to worry about these issues we've got
plenty to do with the habitats that need
improving and expanding yes we do want
more breeding sites for our Birds yes we
do want to make sure that Raptors are
not persecuted and in people who take
them down get prosecuted and I also
welcome the focus from many police
forces on hair coursing but that is why
I won't be supporting reintroductions of
species like Lynx or wolves and we just
don't need to and we won't do
foreign
and delivery from the government now I'm
very conscious there was a concern that
D could have been D for delay I can
assure you I'm determined as a secretary
of state that we will be the department
that delivers in the first hundred days
of the job though we have got on with
delivering I was acutely conscious about
some of the uncertainty as the bpsl
elements start to fall that guaranteed
income income starts to be replaced with
being paid for providing services
that's why arriving in the department
not long after our new farming Minister
I wanted to make sure that more options
were available to Farmers this year so
instead of three new SFI standards we
have six we've also made sure we had an
option to help applian farmers and it
was critical that we included integrated
Pest Management
by using nature-based approaches to
managing pests rather than over Reliance
on pesticides you can reduce your costs
make your farm businesses more resilient
and contribute to better water quality
and thriving Wildlife all while reducing
your carbon emissions I mean frankly
what's not to like
set ourselves a target of 70 of
agricultural land and 70 of farm
Holdings to be covered by our new
farming schemes by 2028 and it's our job
to make the schemes as attractive as
possible so that you want to join and I
hope you will all take a look
going further we know that when Farmers
really work together on these ways of
the helping nature the combined impact
they achieve can be much greater than
the sum of its parts
and to get the most out of Countryside
stewardship which we are not Reinventing
the wheel on we're keeping that going
I've asked officials to design a premium
to encourage Farmers to genuinely join
up and be rewarded with a premium cs
plus so we can get those corridors of
hedgerows or similar to be this super
highway for nature in the countryside I
also introduced a new management payment
of up to a thousand pounds to cover your
costs for delivering SFI we've increased
payment rates under Countryside
stewardship and while Mark Spencer is
closely looking at all of the
recommendations from The Rock review
over 70 of them we wanted to make sure
that new farming schemes deliver for
tenants and we've already acted by
making it easier for tenant Farmers to
participate for example like making
available three-year SFI agreements I
think this Builds on the extensive work
already delivered by concerted
governments with grants a productivity
innovation technology and Equipment
having provided ten thousand Farmers
with support and advice through the
resilience fund ensuring all farmers can
access the successful
sensitive farming program providing seed
funding to the newly created industry
body for agriculture to boost skills and
piloting new ways to support entrance to
the sector
we've announced 45 000 visas we remove
the 25 tariff on Amazing ports in the
USA to help with fee costs we're pushing
ahead with our supply chain reviews into
pigs and dairy which we will conclude
soon but I just want to make sure that
defra will be delivering for you just as
you deliver the Great British food that
we enjoy day in and day out
now lastly I want to recognize that much
of what lies ahead will not be easy we
know that
but it is essential
and we know that if we work together we
can get this done
and get it right
so we do right by each other and right
by Future generations to come
so we hold on to what makes our
Countryside so special
while we secure sustainable resilient
profitable Farm businesses that we need
to keep our country fed for generations
to come
that is one stake and I'll do what I can
to help you see it through so thank you
again for all your hard work and
perseverance and Minette I look forward
to answering questions from your members
thank you very much
Secretary of State thank you very much
indeed I know we're on a tight time
schedule because you have to go back and
vote back to vote
um look if I could get please Richard
Bramley and Lewis barackluff to a
microphone please
um look I'm delighted that the Prime
Minister I've talked a lot about this
domestic food security Summit uh that
he's agreed to to host when I met him
before Christmas he said we must get
that done in the early part of the year
but I'm conscious in August he made some
really important commitments he came to
our headquarters for the for the
hustings Liz trussicles did hers in
London and he talked about you you
mentioned reporting every three years he
talked about annual reporting and
setting a Target and not allowing that
to slip and it was interesting yesterday
the leader of the opposition made a big
play on 50 percent of food to be British
local that was a commitment that he made
do you think those two things will be in
place before the election well in terms
of the reports we have to at least every
three years it's quite a significant
report we've done our first one
um I'm very conscious that I want to
make sure definitely resources are well
structured on trying to get outcomes
um to help and Achieve that I mean we've
said in our Manifesto commitment that we
wanted to keep foods that level of food
production that's absolutely my
intention to do so uh I mean there are
some legal issues
um uh the leader of the opposition
um clearly may not be in tiny um o Faye
with all the different WTO and elements
like that but there's no doubt through
our aspects of our procurement and our
food strategy we're very clear we want
people
um to buy the best that's on offer and
British yeah indeed
I mean we do have a seasonal industry
um so it's not like we can supply every
single bit of food uh that people want
every day of the year and certainly
there's plenty of food we can't produce
at all as you'll be aware but um you
know there's this element that we want
to continue to have a sustainable uh
British farming industry for sure
absolutely Richard Bramley
yes hello
um Secretary of State
um and welcome
um yeah Richard Bramley I'm a farmer
from York chair of the nfu environment
Forum
um government has promised as you've
pointed out that the cap budget will be
returned to Farmers
though we've seen a gradual removal of
the established payments the new schemes
have been slow to offer opportunity to
fill the funding gap on many farms
it'd be very useful to know with full
transparency on how the budget released
from the basic payment scheme has been
returned to Farmers when could you
provide that please
so Richie the point is the money is
there and it's one of the things I've
got a lot of criticism when I arrived
because we didn't get the things out
before Christmas but I wanted to make
sure there were more opportunities for
people to be able to apply for the SFI
standards we wanted to open those up to
tenant farmers and that took a bit of
time but we made those announcements at
the end of January so there is plenty of
opportunity I'm conscious that people
are in different phases of their farming
cycle of uh and when we start to see
particularly the next reduction in the
guaranteed income clearly I expect more
people will want to take advantage of
the different options available so we're
just in that stage right now we're still
in early stages of making that
transition and the money is there the
money is available people can apply for
it I am very conscious Richard that
there are some people who will probably
end up getting a lot more out of the
money and then others decide they don't
want to participate
I want to try and make it easier for
that everybody can participate in one
way or another and having that
flexibility whether that's I think
there's 240 options now under the
countryside stewardship or indeed uh the
the more of the standards that are
coming through so and and more will come
we're still working on aspects of the
SFI but to some extent deliberately as
the proportion of the budget Falls that
is open up to New Opportunities and
that's when we can unrelease a lot more
um different ways of how people can get
their funding streams but it's not all
about government funding of course I
know there's plenty of you who want to
get that eight percent return on using
your land for solar farms and similar
and we want to see more diversification
it's why we've been working with other
aspects of government Department to try
and see what more we can do to make it
easier to have that diversification
and that's activities we're still
working on
and I'm conscious Before Christmas you
published the government's statutory
environmental objectives
um on nature recovery water air quality
tree planting
um and I'm very conscious that the
environmental Improvement plan suggests
that much much of this will fall to
Farmers and indeed the elm scheme to
deliver it and are you relying on the
2.4 billion or do you need to do but do
you know that's the whole point that
we've been on this journey Michael Gove
set it out five years ago the health and
Harmony and indeed it was in our
Manifesto so we're moving that
transition from guaranteed payments
where as I say over half the money went
to 10 to the farmers in landowners just
because the amount of land they had so
here's an opportunity for many many more
people to have access to a greater part
of that 2.4 billion pounds in return for
doing things a lot of which will help
the farming whether that's a healthier
soils or different aspects of how we try
and make that work so it's actually
opened up the opportunity for a lot of
farmers to get a lot more money you
don't think you need to double it or
trouble it uh no I don't think we do
it's been a very clear journey and Okay
I accept some people like the Assurance
of a guaranteed income but I'm trying to
make sure we're delivering what we said
we do in health and Harmony we're
delivering what we said we would do in
the 2019 Manifesto and that is that
Glide path that smooth Glide path is
part of the transition in order to
achieve it Louis Barclay hello
Brooklyn's Farm comprises of about 300
hectares and I've applied for the SFI uh
through the online portal and we had 10
hectares available to put into SFI
um with the reduction of BPS higher
inputs and and and no more available
money to our farm how do you expect
Duplin Farmers to continue and grow as
we provide such a good uh resilience
framework of the rural Countryside
yeah so I think um
so I think one of the things that we're
only really the soil Health standards
available in 2022 that's why I worked
really hard to try and make sure that
there are going to be six standards
available
um now I know the window isn't open yet
I'm pressing the department to really
get on and make sure that is there and
the RPA are busy working on that now so
that there will be more options I expect
for you and farmers in your community to
be able to access more support
potentially from the SFI as well as
other aspects of the schemes
if I could have uh Thomas bins and Jake
fines to the microphone
Lewis makes though you within the
agricultural act have have given the
department yourself
um enormous powers to deal with market
failure which I know was something that
George Eustis felt very very strongly
about
um we've seen huge challenges in the pig
sector
very similar challenges in the poultry
sector and going forwards as we strike
these trade deals at PACE
um BPS has been a big part of dealing
with volatility and indeed market
failure which is why the department
issued and we were very grateful for it
the the split payment coming in the
summer in the winter what plans have you
got to deal with a market failure
situation and use those powers that we
took control of well I think right now
the we're not seeing necessary I
understand the costs are high you know
food inflation is high your input costs
are high that's why we're working on
energy security I'm not necessarily
seeing a market failure
so we saw a market failure with pigs and
poultry well
I'm not sure that we've seen a market
value with poultry we had a billion less
eggs in 2022 to 29. that's not
necessarily a market failure so you know
we've lost businesses hey I'm not
denying that people have chosen
potentially not to restock on certain
things
that's why we're still going through our
supply chain reviews which I've
indicated earlier we're close to
concluding aspects of certainly ondaria
and the pigs and we will consider
potentially other sectors but you know
frankly sometimes it doesn't help when
you have people not humanet it was
somebody else goes to Parliament tells
them there's this massive shortage
of all these problems about the poultry
sector and what a surprise farmers are
going nuts at Christmas time because
they've got a glut of free-range chicken
and they're not getting the prices they
wanted for it you know consumers will
respond if we talk about the potential
of food scandals you know we work so
hard as do you to try and make sure
biosecurity is there we shouldn't be
putting ideas into people's minds that
somehow food is not safe we need to keep
working at Food being safe otherwise
consumers will make different choices so
I'm conscious that uh you know there are
challenges I've accepted that about the
input costs and similar but I'm not uh
saying I don't believe that the I think
it's section 20 the agriculture Act is
there to be invoked because of some of
the challenging economic situations that
we have I'm not seeing it as a market
failure I think you wanted to um
to Jake is it Jake finds and Thomas bins
conference president
Secretary of State um uh Deborah
proposes to publish a land use framework
later this year after 30 years of
environmental schemes farmers are
endlessly being told we are one of the
most nature depleted countries in the
world will the framework help to address
this and with all of the ambitious
programs that you are committed to
um are they committed to baselining our
natural Capital to inform our decision
making and promote private investment
through stacking through ensuring that
we can share rather than spare and we
can produce food and environmental Goods
alongside one another
absolutely I think the um lessons the
early lessons from the pilot landscape
recovery projects are showing that as
much food is being generated as before
and some of that will be aspects of
productivity of aspects like soil health
or slight different ways of doing things
so this is why I believe it's a
symbiotic relationship that can go hand
in hand now thinking through the land
use framework I'm very conscious that
there are different pressures you know
there may be people here who want to put
solar farms getting that guaranteed
income
but there are others who clearly want to
continue to farm that land as well
there's pressure aspects of housing but
overall
about seven percent of our land is used
for farming so and we see different
levels of productivity right across the
country so I think there's still plenty
of opportunity to land this isn't about
stopping farming far from it but it is
making sure that we try and incentivize
appropriately with this public goods
public money for public goods approach
so we can get the best of both worlds in
that regard so we are working on the
framework I'm trying to make sure we
include the other key departments in
doing that
um because uh you know land land isn't
exactly scarce but land does vary in
value and I'm very conscious that the
pricing of land can really make people's
uh change their minds on how they're
going to use it we're starting to see
for example price of land not go to zero
when you plant trees but thinking ahead
of what the carbon markets could be and
it's important that people have this
diversification I think in in their
business recognizing some of the
volatility which I've already indicated
you know things like having the
five-year averaging profits is one way
of perhaps helping smooth cash flow over
that longer term but you know we will
continue to develop it
before we come to Thomas bins could we
have Matthew Donald and Tony bambridge
to the microphone please
Thomas thank you president conference
here in in Stanley
is it me or do I feel that I've been
living through an episode of Yes
Minister
for the last couple of days
it appears and I welcome your
intervention in trying to bring forward
some SFI standards that are applicable
for the Uplands
and that's the first part of Yes
Minister will do that
what the standard of law input grassland
will not be available for a majority of
Upland Farmers because they're already
delivering that particular measure under
Countryside stewardship or higher level
stewardship
so whilst it's a blatantly good effort
to try and bring something that will be
available or could be available it seems
to be undermined by the fact that their
those farmers are already delivering
those that particular measure and many
more which cannot be funded through SFI
so
so can I ask your secretary of state to
sit down with us let's look at the
detail let's see where we can ease this
pain for Upland Farmers by having
measures that allow them access and to
try and retrieve some of the BPS that is
continually taken away from their
businesses
was that
so um Tom was it yeah Tom so Trudy
Harrison is one of your local MPS up in
Cumbria and is a very active voice
within the department
um particularly speaking about Upland
farmers and similar
um I realized I didn't fully answer
Jake's um question earlier about um
stacking so I have said to officials we
need to be a bit more relaxed about
stacking I want to bring people into
this system I don't want all of a sudden
um RPA trying to kind of do multiple
complicated calculations now we're at
the early stage of this transition and I
want people to join it so I'm looking
I'm happy to do some snacking I don't
know if that will be here forever but I
think that we need to get it going and
I'm not seeking to put Farmers out of
business far from it
so I know this is a journey
and there's no point in just being
unkind or being bureaucratic when
actually some of the freedoms are
getting out of the European Union is
they were not just following a system
that was designed for 28 countries and
that we need to continue to try and make
sure that we're doing what is right here
and of course we're not doing the same
thing across the UK either
so we are leading the way
but in leading the way we all have to go
together on this journey I'm very
conscious of that I'll make sure that
that gets done so I will happily make
sure that we get absolutely Tom your
voice and the people you represent
um discussing this in detail on how we
make it work
thank you do you think that point though
on going together bearing in mind that
Scotland and Wales are waiting until
2024 so they are still full uh
direct support full BPS payments do you
think it would not have been better to
agree to framework
I don't think the tail should work the
dog we just need to get on with things
we've got a different farming sector I
mean more broadly defer of course leads
the way on food exports so
GI different things I think we've just
done a pan
o Forest as a way of trying to help with
trade we've managed to get lamb back
into the us so you know we work right
across the UK in some magnificent food
in different parts but there's a clearly
a separation of um Devolution and I
don't want to dictate to the Scots and
the Welsh how they take forward their
industry
so they could stay on the scheme that
they've got at the moment if they think
that's the best thing to do they're
elected as a Scottish government we've
set out a plan very clearly five years
ago
um that was reinforced in the manifesto
and we'll keep going along that Journey
but as I say it's about bringing people
along the journey
we're going to be really quick Matthew
Donald and Tony bambridge very Snappy
thank you modern Minister
um as a pearl to producer bird welfare
is my number one priority and I'm
seriously concerned about the proposals
being looked at by the government
regarding the welfare of animals during
transport our Collective goal should
always be to deliver high standards of
welfare and the proposals around
temperature will impact across all
species
for poultry it will grind the sector to
a halt unnecessarily my question is how
will you ensure any proposals imposed on
the agricultural industry in regards to
welfare transport will deliver the
welfare outcomes we are all striving
towards
well I was struck by something when I
met said recently that we ever seem to
have an Ever Rising ratchet on aspects
of welfare now British consumers care
about Animal Welfare I know you care
about animal welfare and health
so it's important that we move along
that transition as it were carefully but
I'm not intending to keep ratcheting up
different things when I'm conscious of
the transition everybody is going under
with their industry so I'm very happy to
look at that more carefully about
specific issues that concern you
um about the movement of animals within
the country but you know that consumers
care about this stuff so we need to make
we're representing not just Farmers but
consumers as well so we'll we need to
find a way forward on that
previous prime ministers have left
Legacy haven't they
I'm very fortunate to have come back to
defra you know I spent three years
mainly focusing on the environment you
know we have a number of challenges we
have water quality that we want to
improve we've got pollution problems
some of that we need to work more with
aspects of parts of the country on on
some aspects of slavery I get all that
but I'm just saying that we are you know
we have a wider remit to cover and um
that's why some of the interesting
things we've just got to prioritize and
that's why I'm prioritizing making sure
we get this transition for a profitable
sustainable environmentally positive
businesses rise across our country but
we we have raised standards above the EU
we still are I mean that's quite a
challenge uh going forwards if we sit
above everyone else and we allow the
Imports in that don't even meet our
current standards Tony bambridge
yes
[Applause]
thank you president secretary of state
um you will know secretary that
farmers are price takers we are seldom
ever a price maker and we deal with
multinational retailers and food
processors for much of what we produce
and often we get a poor deal
particularly in these inflationary times
there are one or two examples it's fair
uh who deal with Farmers but for many uh
we are getting an unfair deal your
government is very much interested in
free trade you've done many trade
agreements what will you do to try and
ensure that farmers are treated fairly
in the supply chain and how will you do
it
supplier we are doing some of these
supply chain reviews I've mentioned pigs
and dairy we'll consider potentially
other sectors but I we were just
discussing this earlier weren't we
there's um you know there could be a
role for the producer organizations to
be more active in this area uh thinking
of that there's a lot of purchasing kind
of collective power that goes on and
there may be an opportunity for the
farming industry to consider some of
those um kind of doing it the other way
so I don't pretend I've got specific
answers it's not like governments is
going to start setting specific prices
for different products
um but I think they're um there could
well be opportunities on how we help
with the entrepreneurialism aspect of
making sure that fell owners get a good
deal
you've been out to the U.S very recently
their competition at all is completely
different to ours perhaps we could go to
a U.S model and then we could intervene
and talk about price life would be a lot
easier perhaps
well different model
but um you know they're Keen to come
into the market we are trying to make
sure that we have a sensible trade deals
uh in all our discussions with uh right
across government on making sure that we
get the best opportunities for British
Farmers as well both here and abroad
secretary of state has to get a train at
11 15 and I know how long it takes to
get to the station and she's probably
going to have to jog there uh already so
we appreciate your time
um
sorry
I'm not intending to jog there but all
right
we we might we might get on a bicycle
right okay yeah
um look we thank you I mean we haven't
touched the sides really of what is
going on front page of every newspaper
salad shortages Asda rationing that will
be I can't control the weather in Spain
either so uh no but we can be
encouraging these guys to be producing
here and you know I'm conscious that's
something that we that we really need to
hone in on
um there isn't time to discuss it now we
need to come back to it please confront
share your appreciation to the sector
state
thank you
I'm going to documentary thanks
[Music]